see co-founder bass guitarist and
co-lead vocalist for the rock group Kiss
gene simmons has sold more than 100
million albums but his flamboyant
onstage persona rises from a modest
background born in Israel to parents
originally from Hungary Simmons says he
is now living the American dream
his new book called me Inc offers advice
for winning in both business and life so
I came to America and I couldn't speak a
word of English I accessed I did what I
was supposed to do which is it was my
inferred duty to myself to teach myself
the language and remember remember I
don't have a horse in this race English
is my third language so I spoke Hebrew
and Hungarian first but I understood the
combination lock is there to open the
doors of the possibilities of accessing
all the riches you could ever imagine
but it was up to me to educate myself to
learn language skills people skills have
the right thing at the right place and
the right time so meet me Inc sounds
like it's all about me yes it is
gene Simmons tell us the story of how
you felt as a young boy showing your
mother that you could earn money and
then what earning money can do for
people there's unfortunately a sense in
America that the rich especially
self-made rich is somehow negative and
it's just mind-boggling to me because
I've always admired anybody who became a
self-made person and became hideously
rich wonderfully rich so the first thing
I did to my mom when I first got my
first ten million dollar check
I took the ten million dollar check and
I showed it to my mother a Hungarian
Jewish who came to Israel where I was
than America and she looked at it and
she said Vonda for one therefore she had
no sense with all the zeroes meant or
that she just knew that it was a lot of
money and she put it down that she said
and now what are we going to do the
point being that it's never enough and
that's a good thing
talk if you can about the business of
kiss the business of rock and roll and
how you're able to turn that into this
merchandising mega experience business
where you've got things on lunchboxes on
everything tell us how that happened the
history of kiss pretty much started like
any other band for knuckleheads off the
streets of New York who had big dreams
of becoming sort of the American version
of The Beatles on steroids
I was always trained as a young child to
go to school and to learn and to read
voraciously even subjects I wasn't
interested in so when we first started
putting the band together I read
Billboard magazine a record world and
cashbox the weekly Bibles of the
business of music and if you believe in
full disclosure and advertising it says
so right away it says music business it
doesn't just say music so I recognized
that it was a business and I was curious
how does it work what's the price of
goods where's the profit margin what's
the distribution method who what when
where and how
so as the band became got off to a good
start we happen to have some songs
people liked we wore more makeup in
higher heels than your mommy ever did
and so on and so forth and you had a
good partner because you mentioned
Barden it's also very crucial partners
are one of the most important assets not
detriments assets partner up with
somebody who knows something you don't
in that way one and one can equal three
hang out with smarter or better looking
or more successful people than you are
they'll take you up you think Paul
Stanley is better looking than you all
Stanley is a much better looking guy
than I am much more creative and those
things I will never know and likewise
for myself in regards to him one in one
equals three we've been together over 40
years and where we sit now kiss out
selves The Beatles and Elvis we have
more licensing and Merchandising
products than almost any band out there
which is to say we have a kiss golf
course in Las Vegas and we're going on a
kiss Cruise in about a week that
restaurants have well that's a non
cross-collateralized business rock and
brews which is our restaurant Jean has
nothing to do with kiss I'm one of the
owners of that we have la kiss which is
non crossed with the kiss model which is
the only football team in Los Angeles
part of the book also includes a
foreword by John Varvatos and he
describes his upbringing outside of
Detroit and the various jobs that he
took he was going to go into medicine
was there something that you were going
to go into but you saw the success of
music in the music business I studied to
be a rabbi but that's not where I wound
up so I wound up teaching sixth grade
which was a left-hand turn and then I
wound up joining a rock band and that
was a right-hand turn and now here I sit
on top by some standards on Empire where
there are different business models that
are non cross that have their own income
streams and own profit centers and I'm
telling you the only way to do that is
to educate yourself opportunity is not
going to knock on your door Justin
Bieber what do you think about him and
his
Bieber happens to have the right thing
at the right place and the right time
the industry in the marketplace had just
tens of millions of young
twelve-year-old girls without their own
Elvis he came along at the right time
he's very talented the good-looking
young kid he's clearly making some bad
life choices but he's young the author
of the new book me Inc build an army of
1 unleash your inner rock God win in
life and business
go get the world it's waiting for you to
take over come on